okay so what's our controversy of the
day spin the wheel of controversy to
find out what subject we-we-we decided
to fight about today and well today it
was birthright citizenship President
Trump said that he wants to abolish
birthright citizenship for illegals that
is the the law that automatically makes
the citizen the the children of illegal
immigrants citizens if they're born here
he wants to abolish that via executive
what our what he's saying is that you
you shouldn't be able to if you're you
know a an illegal immigrant shouldn't be
able to just run across the border and
then give birth and all of the sudden
her child is a citizen and then by
extension as she is as well because of
course we're not supposed to be breaking
up the families so that's that's his
point I think it's a rational one
logical one a lot to be said for it but
this set off the outrage machine of
course the outrage machine did what it
always does did what it does best which
is be outraged and it also prompted more
reasonable responses from people who
pointed out that well you can't amend
the constitution via executive order
that's not how it works here's what the
Constitution currently says on the topic
okay fourteenth amendment says all
persons born or naturalized in the
United States and subject to the
jurisdiction thereof our citizens of the
United States and of the State wherein
they reside the jurisdiction thereof
piece that that's the piece that where
it's kind of ambiguous and an argument
can be made that the children of
illegals are not actually protected by
the Fourteenth Amendment now obviously
this executive order is going to end up
in the courts will end up probably in
the Supreme Court and then finally maybe
we'll get a reading on what exactly the
14th amendment means and who it protects
and and all of that I'll leave it to
others to talk about the constitutional
issues of this and to dissect all of
that I just want to make a couple points
in principle about birthright
citizenship and the ideas behind it
really I just want to make one point I
guess and that is that it's it's funny
to me that liberals constantly argue
that the Constitution is the
outmoded outdated archaic document
written by people who had no idea what
sort of country we would be centuries in
the future and therefore it's obsolete
and therefore there's no reason why we
should take it seriously or listen to it
they say that but then on something like
birthright citizenship something that
we're you know 19th century Americans
came up with this with this thing way
before we had an influx of millions upon
millions of immigrants flooding into the
to the country so on that issue they say
no it cannot be updated it is sacrosanct
it is law it's sacred scripture and it
cannot be changed or amended which so it
seems to me that we've really got this
backwards because with something like
free speech religious liberty the right
to self-defense these are basic
fundamental human principles about your
your your natural rights as human beings
and so those are going that is that that
is that's timeless that's always going
to be the case so the fact that it was
written down on paper hundreds of years
ago that doesn't matter
because it's just as relevant now as it
was hundreds of years ago because these
are timeless ideas but when it comes to
you know what makes someone a citizen is
someone a citizen if they just so happen
to be born here these are not timeless
eternal concepts and I think the the
context and the situation and all that
all really matters right now I think
there's plenty of ambiguity to justify
excluding illegal immigrants from the
birth rate law but I would be in favor
of abolishing birthright citizenship for
the children of illegals outright I
think the Constitution should be amended
accordingly something that I know will
never happen because that would require
a significant number of Republicans and
Democrats to vote in favor of it which
won't happen but as a matter of
principle I think that the part of the
amendment which potentially allows this
has overstayed its usefulness and thus
should be should be amended the the
founders did not know and could not have
known that we would have this flood of
illegals coming into a country which by
the way would already be inhabited by
300 million people do you think they had
that in mind no they didn't it is
clearly madness in my view to allow for
a situation where a person need only
make it across the border have a baby
and their baby is a citizen on
technicality it imbues this kind of like
weird supernatural power on the physical
land itself it seems like something from
ancient times it seems like some ancient
law or if you are born on this land you
are a part of the land that you belong
to the land because you were born here
this is not this is strikingly
old-fashioned and impractical for us now
and liberals are usually the ones
complaining about old-fashioned
impractical things well here this really
is so it should be changed just there's
a there's a test that I like to apply I
call it the cave test especially when
we're evaluating laws and legal
principles and those sorts of things we
should try to think of it try to imagine
that we've just emerged from a cave and
we've we've never heard of this idea
before totally foreign to us and then
someone suggests it or asks about like
hey what do you think about this what
would our reaction be now I know that
this test doesn't always work but the
point is that there are a lot of things
in the country a lot of laws a lot of
policies that we kind of accept because
it's always been that way and it's just
how it is and we were born into that
system and so we don't really question
it so I think it helps sometimes to just
imagine how we would react if we had
never heard of it before and someone and
someone brought it up I always do this
with Social Security imagine imagine you
never heard of imagine forget about the
cave imagine
no Social Security did not exist the
system didn't exist there was no thought
of the system and then one day a
politician got up there and suggested it
and said hey I've got an idea here's an
idea how about the government takes
money from your paycheck every single
week keeps it and holds on to it for
decades and will actually use it
oh I say hold on hold on to actually
does not hold on hold on to it at all
but takes it and uses it for other
things and then once you get older
they'll start paying it back to you in
small chunks without interest now if
someone suggested that that system to
you and we had never heard of I think
almost everyone the country would say no
that's crazy what do you what no I don't
want that why in the world would I would
no no no thank God right I'll just take
my money and put in a savings account
and keep interest and then I'll take it
out when I want thank you very much
that's a crazy system that makes no
sense what we only tolerate it because
it's all because in from our perspective
it's always been that way I think
birthright citizenship is kind of the
same thing we're just we're used to the
idea of anchor babies but but imagine
that this concept didn't exist and then
someone suggested it they said I've got
an idea how about this if you if you are
a citizen of any other country on the
globe and you're pregnant all you have
to do is get across the border somehow
you can illegally works okay you can do
it illegally sneak across have the baby
and your whole family gets to stay I
think if someone suggested that policy
and it never existed before almost
everyone would say yeah you know no I
don't I don't know about that that
there's some problems there not to
mention let's think about this what
happens when immigrants from another you
know when someone comes from another
country and they have a child here what
often happens are they are they told by
their parents you're an American
you're part of this culture of this
people this is your identity is that
what they're told no I think I think or
it's not always with often it's not so
often it seems like immigrant families
they come here they retain their own
culture their own national identity and
loyalty they speak their own languages
at home they even set up their own
communities where they kind of rebuild
the home country in these little small
microcosms and that's what they do my
point is that they want their children
to be conferred the benefits of
citizenship but they don't want their
children to really actually identify as
or see themselves as Americans now I
know that's a generality like that's not
the case every in every case but it is
often the case so that's that's why I
don't like birthright citizenship I
think it's impractical it's arbitrary
it's it's not accompanied by
assimilation which i think is a really
important point here and this is the
problem with immigration in general
these days legal and illegal it has
become it seems like immigration has
become a very one-sided thing it seems
like the immigrant the immigrant gets
the benefits of citizenship but does not
necessarily make any effort to
assimilate any effort to be a part of
the country and what's more he's coming
into a country that's already been
established already been built and
that's the difference between the new
immigrants and the immigrants of the
19th century and even the early 20th
century and that's why these comparisons
don't hold up when people try to draw
these comparisons and say well you know
how dare you be have this feeling of
immigration you're you know your family
came here at some point as well your
family was immigrants well that's that's
true but it was a very different thing
immigrants back in the old days they
were coming here and they were taking
part in the project of building and
establishing this country they came to a
work in progress as the point the modern
immigrant does not he comes into an
already built structure hoping to
benefit from the shelter that it
provides him which which if that's done
legally that's fine it's understandable
I would want to do that too if
I didn't live here but it's also why I
think we need to take a different
approach to modern immigration and think
of it differently because it's just it's
an entirely different situation in my
opinion alright one other thing I wanted
to talk about after the events of of
last week with a mass shooting to mass
shootings actually and the pipe bomb
attempts as well there's been all of the
usual discussions that come up around
these kinds of events have have come up
again and there have been people saying
as usual that we need to have a
conversation about mental illness you
know we need to talk about mental
illness mental illness is one of the
things that we normally blame these acts
of evil on along with guns and policies
and politics and so on now I don't think
that guns policies politics can at all
cause a person to go out and slaughter
11 people at a synagogue I do think that
mental illness can at least be a factor
it plays a part it would be absurd to
deny the involvement of mental illness
and to say that it plays no part
whatsoever so it doesn't make sense to
talk about mental illness but I don't
think that mental illness is the main
thing and I get nervous about these
discussions I get nervous about pinning
evil on Mental Illness and I get nervous
when when when that is the the take away
that people take from this when they see
this kind of something or that's a crazy
person that's a mentally ill person they
should have been on medication so that's
what we need to do we need to you know
we need to have better mental health
when that's the primary take away I get
nervous about that and I tell you why
two reasons first when we say that a
person did something like this because
of mental illness we are removing agency
were removing free will from the
perpetrator which means for one thing
we're going far too easy on him and in
the process we're being I think unfair
to his victims after all who can the
families really be be angry at if the
killer was simply ill was sick
and was was driven to this by his
sickness which he had no control over I
don't think that's really fair to the
families to say that now it may not help
the families to be told that well this
was a man who chose to do this it wasn't
because he was sick it's because he
chose to do it may not help them to know
that or be told that but I do think they
should know that they deserve to know
that they deserve to be angry at this
individual person for choosing to do
what he did
choosing it this is not just another
victim whose it was a victim of some
kind of illness no this was a person who
chose to be a predator and should be
blamed for it 100%
the implication when we blame mental
illness for the synagogue shooting or
for any other shooting our attack or
whatever kind of other atrocity the
implication obviously is that mental
illness caused the event to occur and if
the illness caused that then we cannot
say that the individual person himself
the killer caused it by his choice and I
just think that that's simply false I
think it is a choice I do not think that
any mass shooting has ever occurred
which was which was carried out by
someone who had no choice I do not think
that there has ever been
in fact I'll say I don't think that
there's even this maybe maybe it's just
too extreme of this day but I don't
think that there has ever been a crime
committed by someone who had no control
over their actions and so I don't think
there's ever been a crime that could be
completely blamed on mental illness and
I know that we have the insanity defense
and it rarely works sometimes it does I
don't think I should ever work because
even in the case of a really crazy but
someone who's clearly delusional and and
you know someone who would appeared up
to us to be for lack of a better term
crazy I don't think you can prove and I
don't think there's any reason to
believe that a person like that has no
consciousness no awareness of what
they're doing has no freewill whatsoever
I don't think you can prove that
and I think any person who's walking
around talking you know doing things
anyone like that they at some level they
have consciousness at some level as a
human being they're making choices and
so they should be held accountable for
them now if you want to which is which
is which is why by the way which is why
in these in the cases of I'm trying to
think of let's think of a mass shooting
that was committed by someone who now
this the synagogue shooter I don't think
there's any reason at all to assume that
he was crazy
this was someone overcome by bigotry and
hate but let's take the the theater
shooting in Colorado a few years ago now
there was someone obviously obviously
very troubled again lack of a better
term let's let's let's call him crazy
but this was not someone who was walking
around casually for days and weeks
leading up to it just telling people
that he's going to be going and shooting
up a movie theater he may have written
it in notebooks or confided with a
therapist or something like that but but
if this is someone who really doesn't
know right from wrong there's no idea
right from wrong is no idea what they're
doing then they shouldn't be making any
effort whatsoever to conceal their plans
and or to get away with it if there's
any effort taken to conceal to get away
with it anything like that's clearly an
indication that this person knows they
should be doing it
so a the only time I think that you
could maybe blame a crime on mental
illness is if this is someone who really
had no idea that what they were doing
was even wrong but in these mass
shootings that's just that's just never
the case there's always some element of
planning going into it always some
element of secrecy and all that kind of
stuff so if you want to tell me that
mental illness is partly why a person
would want to do something like this in
the first place
then I would agree with you because it
certainly is a disordered abnormal sick
thing to want to do it is a it is a not
only a destructive choice it's a
self-destructive choice because the
person carrying out the attack stands to
gain nothing at least gain nothing that
a sane person would want to gain they're
going to be killed or they're gonna end
up in jail for the rest of life maybe
that's part of what they want part of
why they're doing it which again is a
disordered crazy thing to desire but the
act is still a choice the act is
something they choose to do even a
mentally ill person has that choice so a
mentally ill person may discover within
themselves this depraved dark desire to
go and hurt someone and maybe we can pin
that on Mental Illness but they still
have to choose to go and really do it
and in that sense if they if they do
make that choice and they go and they
actually do it then mental illness was
basically irrelevant you can't say well
as mentally ill I wanted to do it I
don't care what you wanted to do you
still did it it doesn't matter to me at
all what kind of desires were in your
head or to what why does that matter
fact is this was a horrible evil thing
and you chose to do it that's all but I
think there's another problem with with
blaming mental illness and that is that
it paints a rather disturbing picture of
human beings I think this idea that a
person can go crazy and then go kill a
bunch of people I think if that's true
if we are if we are nothing but material
if our consciousness is just a product
of chemistry and nothing more and if
these evil actions are then the result
of bad chemistry or chemistry going awry
or things firing how they're not
supposed to fire and chemicals doing
things chemicals aren't supposed to do
well that's the case and there's no will
there's no choice in it then then then
how can we ever trust anyone ever again
how can we trust ourselves how can we
ever be around anyone ever again how do
you know that your spouse
or your best friend won't contract this
illness and then one day through no
fault of his own go out and do something
terrible or kill you or whatever
now clearly people spouses friends
children do make these decisions and
usually when they make these decisions
the family will claim that oh I did it
we didn't see this coming we had no idea
but I think in most of those cases when
you find out about this person and you
find out the background even though the
family and the friends may be claiming
that this came out of the blue and they
had no idea if they really had no idea
it's because obviously they weren't
paying attention and they didn't know
this person as well as they thought they
did but my point is that it is possible
to know a person it is possible to say
of a person well they wouldn't make that
choice I trust that that's something
they wouldn't do because that's an evil
choice and they simply wouldn't do that
because I know them now you could say
that you can be wrong you could think
you know someone and you don't but but
but the point is it is possible to be
sure at least reasonably sure that a
person will not become a serial killer
because you know that they simply
wouldn't make that choice because you
understand them on some deeper level
that goes beyond just the chemicals in
their brain but again this is all
chemicals if it's all mental illness
that causes these things then you can
never really be sure of anyone would be
safe around anyone in that case I can't
say that I trust that my wife won't
murder me in my sleep because to say
that would be like saying well I trust
that she'll never get cancer which is
nonsense I hope my wife doesn't get
cancer I pray she doesn't but
statistically there is a whatever
percent chance that my wife will get
cancer you look at her demographics you
look at different in your family history
age all that there is that you could put
a percentage on it and say there's this
percent chance of her getting cancer and
as she gets older that percentage goes
up right so there's no whatever whatever
I hope there is no trust involved here
because she has no control over that and
that's the same for everyone
if these evil actions are simply
symptoms of disease then we would have
to say the same in that case I would
have to say well I hope my wife doesn't
kill me in my sleep I hope she doesn't
become a serial killer but there is a
whatever percent chance that she will
and there's just simply no way to you
know it so you could you could look at
the statistics and look at probabilities
and you know that's the percentage but
if I say even if I said well there's a
point zero one percent chance that my
wife is will become a serial killer even
that I wouldn't I wouldn't feel safe
going to sleep around her to be honest
even more so I wouldn't I wouldn't be
able to trust myself around anyone
because I have to say the same about
myself
because how do I know I won't get this
sickness how do I know that chemicals
and things won't start doing weird
things in my head and force me to do
things outside of my outside of my
choice outside of my agency then in that
case I must look at myself and say there
is a certain percent chance that I'm the
next Charles Manson and I you I don't
think we could talk about people that
way because people do have free will and
choice and they decide to do evil things
and so that's the conversation that that
is the first primary most important
conversation that we should be having
around these around these kinds of
events rather than talking about mental
illness we talk about a night you know I
mentioned this yesterday but we talk
about evil this is a person who chose to
do an evil thing and then the other
thing too is and I mentioned this before
but and I'm you know I'm the last one to
complain about stigmas and that kind of
thing I think though I think that the
idea that the term stigma is way
overused but when you blame stuff like
this on mental illness all the time it
does create a stigma around mental
illness because what we're saying then
about actually mentally ill people is
hey they could I mean they could go off
anytime and kill somebody which is not
the case because they'd still
to choose it so we can't loose we can't
lose sight of choice when when talking
about this all right we'll we'll leave
it there thanks for watching thanks for
listening everybody Godspeed